[Music]
in more fees news submitted by Laci from
Toronto
Ola see who's Laci
she's from Toronto you anyway I'm in a
DMV wants to charge motorists a fifteen
dollar fee just for walking in the door
the DMV [ __ ] them I like this idea
though I like you too
because we're rich like yeah charge us
all to change your I do two Meg's real
[Applause]
when I was at the DMV I was like why is
it the Triple A the only like business
outside the DMV that's actually trying
to do DMV [ __ ] and it's 10 times faster
yes International in case you don't know
what the DMV is it's the Department of
Motor Vehicles which is a government
office that you go in to get your
driver's license or take your driving
test or get your registration it's the
worst always packs there's lots of
stand-up comics that do jokes about how
long the line oh my god yes it's about
it to our with a minimum process so now
this one DMV and Rhode Island actually
yeah the railroad they would in Rhode
Island sure hope that rich people are
yeah so they are saying that they want
to apply a $15.00 in person customer
service fee and that's in order to deter
people from going in to do things that
they could have done online so it would
apply to license and registration
renewals but it would not apply to Real
ID license renewal so so in the United
States we have to get this new ID called
Real ID you have to go in person to get
it or not you need a passport to travel
and domestically October 20 21 I think
October 20 20 20 I think
well 2020 why because now it's like more
secure like I don't know I haven't
gotten a Tennessee validator validation
now exactly
now again oh man yeah mom I'm gonna get
you guys all blue checkmarks no don't
have it don't you have one Nicky you
have all of them except well that's what
she bit is my daughter from subscribing
to JK news because people are watching
it they're not subscribing us there's
not subscribe our Channel right now so
they should do right do it that
checkmark so all of us could get the
check we will validate that you have
subscribed I'm so stupid I thought you
were really gonna get his check mark no
I am oh well that's a story for another
time to anyone huh it's a story for
another time that's all you need to know
it's coming I'll tell you how later okay
I'm not the ROC recently you met so many
questions anyway so it's an in person
$50 customer service fee and there's
another 15 dollar fee that they want to
impose that will hit motorists renewing
a license or registration that has
already expired honestly I will pay a
[ __ ] hundred dollars to get in and
get out in five minutes I would be I
would when I said were rich what I meant
is that usual bank account is loaded
what is that usually when you go to the
DMV I have avoided going to the DMV to
get another license because mine got
swiped stolen yeah my bag got stolen in
Barcelona so this was like almost a year
ago Tom I know it's really bad I should
get my license and then I'm in Culver
City and the line is like way out like
two miles away from that DMV everything
yeah and if I didn't think that it was
gonna it would take me like four hours
to get through the line and get the
website suck still yeah try a different
day of the office so $15 to save me four
hours
if that many let's say even 50% of those
people were not gonna go because of the
feed yeah exactly I would pay so if you
make more than seven dollars an hour it
would be you're rich too that's what I
met
we're not that rich I mean we would just
pay the fifteen dollars happily yeah I'm
a job pay a hundred dollars if you gave
me on five minutes yeah I'll give a [ __ ]
I'll pay that [ __ ] because that won't
pay my employees but I'll pay the
[ __ ] DMV to get me a got into in the
front of the line that's that's for sure
yep the DMV fast I'd be so cool if there
was fast sizes for real life stuff yeah
because then you could go get your
shopping done you especially the one in
Santa Barbara's next to Costco you could
go get all your Costco Safi then and
then you're like oh [ __ ] now it's time
so what's the window I don't know I just
don't understand why they can't get it
done right yeah that's what I was gonna
say is I don't know if this is actually
gonna work because the problem isn't the
too many people that the DMV the problem
is how slow they are got the same exact
thing when you go to triple-a it just
you can do things in under five minutes
all the time so they can have less
people but when you go to a counter and
they still don't give you eye contact
they're still go fumbling through their
papers they're having the side
conversation a lot of side conversation
and they're like is this your lunch hour
I went to go pick up my custom license
plate and it's just in a shelf right and
I can go oh here's my thing can I just
get my license plate they could have
handed it to me and it could have been
an under ten second thing they're like
talking oh yeah better like talking
about was have it on the news and I'm
like what the [ __ ] and I'm here for like
five minutes then all of a sudden I'm a
clock out real quick and then so that
person how do you tell someone else I
want you to pick up his license plate to
change shifts and then I'm like what the
[ __ ] wiser is this giant Fiasco when you
can literally go like this
I want you have to tell someone that
okay this guy is here for it's custom
license plate but now you're going off
to lunch it's just so it's crazy and
they don't get
me changing my address in getting my
registration card took me like less than
five minutes but I waited for over two
hours yeah yeah well you know what it
also it is is an old people feet because
like even if they don't want to pay $15
a lot of old people don't want to use
the Internet
so they're more scared yeah I mean like
me too like so my grandparents they
don't know how to not my mom but like my
grandma's don't know how to use the
internet very well my dad doesn't trust
the internet so he'll like go in person
he still like makes physical checks and
stuff my mom - yeah he doesn't like pay
bills online um yeah and so like there's
old people that are like oh man I don't
want to pay $15 but I don't know how to
use the internet so it's kind of a yeah
they're saying that the average customer
wait time it
it used to be 39 minutes in 2016 then
went 1530 it well this is pretty like
the Rhode Island one okay and then 59
minutes and - 2017 and then 63 minutes
and 2018 I bet I could like run a whole
presidential candidacy on how it's
[ __ ] up the DMV is and when I'm
already voted for yeah yeah mm-hmm I'll
fix the DMV system that's the only thing
people care about me yep in California
was I think 400 minutes
I know and then like I mean for sure the
DMV employees like I mean I don't know
what happened there but just by viewing
and witnessing like what happens when I
go in I'm like this could definitely be
ran better but it's also the people that
go in cuz you guys remember when we went
for a motorcycle license
there's a [ __ ] four house in Eternia
we went to like seven different windows
there's one channel I've to the smaller
towns mm-hmm like I drew drive 30
minutes extra - oh really yeah we did I
went to four of them what I'm trying to
complain about here too is like the the
people's demeanor like like us like
there were people cutting in line when
we were waiting there forever and it's
just like the [ __ ] dude like we had an
appointment - yeah a point man it was
four hours yeah that's cut in line when
you have a number number like this one
chick and then there were all these
people - like it's just cut in line and
we're like yeah there were security
there is but they don't care they're not
trying to they're all government
employees yeah they should privatize it
cuz then they get charged even more
exactly like some sort of like communist
or something like everyone's like oh we
need universal health care evolved
because then the government woman no
government sucks at running please even
when I was broke I didn't want the
government to run [ __ ] because you know
what I was broke I hated the DMV and I
was like I would much rather pay more to
get better services at triple-a dude
there was this one horrific experience
that I had that actually led me to like
crying my eyes out cuz I'm like I don't
know what the [ __ ] did do anymore and it
was cuz they were forcing me to do this
thing over the phone and like they hit
they were making me say like the numbers
but like the alpha-beta whatever like
the a stable inside it was your exit I
don't know it could probably could've
had
but I could not for the life of me get
them to understand what I was thinking
and I couldn't let me transfer me to an
actual person and then I actually went
in person and listen I can't [ __ ] do
this on the phone they're like sorry
this could only be by the phone oh my
god that's so sad crazy soon ago though
there are things that you could only do
on the website how did you go there but
you're the only reason why either there
is because the websites not clear so you
go there and you go can you help me with
this and well you have to go back on the
website you don't win they don't but are
they gonna take this $15 and give it to
more efficient workers or so so they're
saying that this program wait let me see
that they're the budget requests are
seeking 2.2 million dollars next year to
keep extra staff working after next
October's deadline to get real IDs and
so they're proposing that by doing this
$15 fee that they will be getting an
additional 1.5 million dollars a year
it's so stupid because then why can't
teachers get more money like it's also
run by the government schools and stuff
and then they're like hey taxes and then
they never give it to the teachers but
then this so like let's invent something
where people have to work extra the real
ID thing mm-hmm and then and then we'll
charge the people more and it will give
a money maker work for tips
exclusively for tip oh whoa what the
damn B yeah and they'd be nice they know
they know what car you're driving
already so they know who their true
how about themselves because she goes
we're rich then she goes wait I think
they should privatize this complete
misty goats will they know what kind of
car I Drive I'm gonna tip with the real
rich ones are like driving cameras yeah
[ __ ] the DMV that's all I gotta say
[Music]